I'm Matt I'm Dave and we're flavour
tripping we're flavour treatment
I just hate like super sleep Oh what the
hell taste only sweet I don't know it's
like trick lemon or something oh my god
that just turned it into like lemonade
fridge it's like candy it's like almost
too sweet why aren't people just doing
this all the time I taste amazing it
tastes like candy just tipping me out
today I actually could eat all of this
like no problem when you touch these
peppers isn't it like dangerous if you
like touch your face well for the first
time in my entire life I'm gonna bite
into a pepper why does this taste so
good
I'm not feeling a burn actually it
doesn't taste spicy at all yeah it like
physically hurts but it doesn't taste by
feet I've made a terrible mistake
I guess the tip isn't that spicy that's
what she said it tastes exactly like a
bell pepper but like a bell pepper that
punched you in the tongue Oh God
sorry delayed punch this is scary this
is the scariest thing boy you smell it
and your brains like oh don't do that
here we go okay
oh it's good oh I know I burn apple
cider vinegar that oh it's burning so
I've actually heard that this tastes
like chocolate milk what what stuff whoo
it's like sweeter like a flat soda oh
wow yeah I also feel like it's a good
way to promote binge drinking does it
taste like chocolate cake this makes it
go down a lot smoother I'm not sure
that's a great thing some things you
don't want to be super sweet yeah at the
end of the day the most important thing
to take away from this is never drink
vinegar flavor tripping or not agree